[Music]
it's one of those did I really see that
TV moment in season 8 episode 3 of Game
of Thrones we see our jumping towards
night King and stabbing him in the heart
with a Valyrian steel dagger chauvinist
David Benioff and DB vice claimed that
they have known for years that she would
be the one to kill the night king but
you might not have spotted all the clues
that they put in other episodes we're
gonna break it down for you right from
the start in season 1 episode 1 ru is
introduced to us as a force to be
reckoned with
while her brother bran is set up to not
be a great warrior
Arya comes in with a sneak attack and
hits the target season 1 episode 2 ru is
bestowed with her first weapon needle by
John John services stickin with the
pointy end this line is repeated in the
long night picking with the pointy end
all use teacher after John was Syrio
Forel who taught her to be fast coining
the phrase
what do we say to the god of death not
today which again was repeated in the
long night ironically in her first
lesson with him he throws a sword
towards her which he fails to catch the
model you will dodge the cat's paw
daggers journey through the seasons is
actually a clue in itself it makes an
early appearance in season 1 a
mysterious assassin tries to murder Brad
with it but Catelyn Stark protects him
so cat then takes her to King's Landing
where she shows it little vinkor he
frames Tyrion which then turns into the
war of the five kings now Stark has it
been loose its little finger but he
betrays him leaves Ned Stark's death
with and since area on her long journey
to becoming a badass nothing only the
little finger tease give it back to bran
at the same location it was first
introduced in season 7 episode 1 that
exact dagger shows up in one of the
books
Sam is reading in The Citadel in Old
Town to find out how to defeat the army
the dead and the night King Melisandre
meets earlier in season 3 episode 6
telling her I see a darkness in you
and in that darkness eyes staring back
at me brown eyes blue eyes very nice
eyes you'll shut forever this is the
promptness Andre uses again in season 8
episode 3 to send her over to the
weirwood tree in season 4 Aria picks up
a few tips from the Hound in their
travels across Westeros
he teaches her to look for weak spots in
armor and also how to stab someone in
the heart in season 6 episode 5 bran has
a vision where he experiences the
creation of a night king by the children
of the forest what we now know is the
night King gets stabbed in the chest by
a dragonglass dagger it's under a
similar-looking weirwood tree that he
would meet his demise again being
pierced in the chest in season 8 episode
1
Arya sneaks up on Jon Snow in exactly
the same place where she kills annoyed
King he says how did you sneak up on me
in season 7 episode 4 brand gives all
year the dagger that he interned was
given by Littlefinger the little finger
seen had seemed a bit random at the time
and he turns it over to her saying I
don't want it it's a testament to Isaac
William hempstead portrayal of bran that
without realising its significance he
has a wistful and kind of knowing look
on his face as if giving the dagger some
significance
once Bryan gives the dagger to Arya is
extremely visible on her belt throughout
the next episodes she then uses it in a
sparring match with Brienne using the
same drop move that she did with the
night king characters died protecting
alia almost as if saving her life is the
main objective
so beric Dondarrion and Syrio Forel then
we come to season 8 episode 3 itself The
Hound has a seemingly distracting
breakdown during the episode saying to
sir Berek death it replies to point to
Arya and say tell her that I also
repeats moves during the episodes we've
seen her do in previous fights her first
encounter with a white mimics her season
6 training with the faceless men
stopping the staff in the same position
it should have been obvious that ru was
being built up something special
throughout the show she's gone through a
lot of try
it was never really clear what this
training would be for other than killing
people on her list we now know that it
was to save the Seven Kingdoms from its
most dangerous adversary did you support
any other clues that we missed comment
below
[Music]